Amy Klobuchar drops out of the race
Chris Matthews drops out of MSNBC and
Joe Biden has a super Monday we will
examine how the Dems are pulling out all
the stops to stop Bernie before Super
Tuesday then MSNBC pushes out Chris
Matthews after 20 years we will take a
look at the bogus me to reasoning and
then go deeper to what's really behind
the ouster all that and so much more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
we simply do not have enough time to get
to everything that changed yesterday in
the left-wing world but we will do our
best and first we got to thank our
friends over at quip you know how
important it is to have nice clean
bright white teeth okay I'm not exactly
an Adonis of a man I'm not like an
Olympian or Hercules or something but
you know I've always had pretty nice
teeth and it's always helped me out with
the ladies well quip makes brushing your
teeth twice a day for two minutes and
flossing simple starts with an electric
toothbrush refillable floss an anti
cavity toothpaste equips electric brush
has sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
guide a full and even clean the quip
floss dispenser comes with pre-marked
streets you know how to use just exactly
enough may I'm always a little bad about
it so it really really helps if you go
to get quip dot-com slash michael mi CH
AE l right now you will get your first
refill for free
you need an electric toothbrush guys get
into the 21st century you need it
go get quip you will get your first
refill free at get quip comm slash
michael GE t qu IP comm slash michael
quit the good habits company amy
klobuchar drops out yesterday endorses
joe biden Pete boo de jedge drops at two
days ago endorses Joe Biden beta L Roark
drops out what seems like centuries ago
endorses Joe Biden nobody really cares
but he's gonna do it anyway
Susan Rice didn't run for president
didn't drop out did lie to Americans
about Benghazi but she also endorsed Joe
Biden yesterday former Senate Majority
Leader Harry Reid
forget about him I'd forgotten about him
too now unfortunately got to remember
him because he endorsed Joe Biden sleepy
Joe sweeping up all of these big big
endorsements we will get to what it
means first let's turn to Mayor Pete who
went out campaigned with Biden himself
and endorsed the former vice president
well it takes at its best is more than
policy its Soulcraft and so it's fitting
that I am joining to support a campaign
that speaks so often about the
soul of this nation I don't believe the
world is divided up into people who are
all good and people who are all bad I
don't believe that how you voted in the
past makes you good or bad I believe
each of us can have good things and bad
things brought out of us and that's why
leadership is so important I'm looking
for a leader I'm looking for a president
who will draw out what is best in each
of us and I'm encouraging everybody who
was part of my campaign to join me
because we have found that leader in
vice president soon to be President Joe
Biden mayor Pete's endorsement is just
like his campaign contrived cliche and
secretly radical right it's it's kind of
an empty endorsement we need politics to
unify us to bring us together it's we're
not all bad people are all good people
were were people and we need politics
and politicians do politics and we found
a politician who does politics in Joe
Biden forward together unity unity
forward Biden okay so you just say all
right whatever you're just people judge
just likes the way that his voice sounds
so that's where the best thing he's got
going for him as a candidate is this
voice as a sort of nice tone to it I use
as a bunch of cliches and then there's
there's that little secret radicalism
right the way he opens up is he says
politics is Soulcraft and unity and Joe
Biden and togetherness and moving
forward and together you say hold on
wait go what did you just say go back to
that first one about the unity no no no
before that bet the about that
togetherness no after that
oh the soulcraft now this is something
that I think the left really believes I
think most left-wingers believe it P
Buddha judge just gives you a little
glimpse into it they believe that the
purpose of politics is not to just sort
of get along together in civil society
or to defend a tradition that we've all
inherited or to protect the rights that
are given to us in our constitution in
our laws that are protected by our
institutions now it's
soulcraft takes on this religious aspect
because for the left the state has all
the power all
the is do all of the reverence of a
religious institution and they believe
that human nature is infinitely
malleable so you know conservatives tend
to believe that the human nature is
nature right you're born with it it's
set it's broken it's never gonna be
perfected we're never going back to the
Garden of Eden the left doesn't think
that they think with just a little bit
more time or a little bit more money
they will be able to perfect human
nature we'll end up in Utopia that's
that the Marxist program was to perfect
human nature it's every leftist utopian
program and and that's what people you
to judge believes as well which is
unsurprising you know is he talks like a
moderate he walks like a moderate he
endorses like a moderate but every so
often you had a glimpse of that
radicalism which really is the
generational shift they talk in this in
this endorsement that how the real
difference between Joe and Budaj edges
generational well I guess that's true
but the sad thing is if Pete Budaj is
the moderate of his generation it shows
you just how much further to the left
the Millennials have gone so Joe Biden
is very excited to get this this
endorsement so he comes up there and as
always just flatters and flatters and
flatters if you've supported a man of
enormous integrity a fellow who has as
much moral courage as yes physical
courage I really mean that like oh he he
had a backbone like he has a backbone
like a ramrod he I really mean this I
think about it if Pete had been around
another six years I wouldn't be standing
here Pete be standing I'd be endorsing
Pete no I really mean yes so when you
have to set off a certain statement that
you're saying by saying no no I really
mean that what you are implying is that
for other things that you say you don't
really mean them it's like when people
say hey look I'm gonna be honest you say
well what were you before where you were
lying to me before but now you're gonna
be honest okay if you have to set off
the true statements by saying no no I
really mean that
then I have no reason to believe that
you really believed the thing you say
you mean right now because it means that
you don't mean men
of your statement so it's very possible
that you don't mean the statement no no
I really mean that but this is Joe
Biden's problem it's not the Joe Biden
is I don't think he's a nefarious you
know pre-planned a sociopath liar I
think he has no regard for the truth I
think he doesn't care about the truth at
all and so he just flatters and
ingratiates
and gladhands and compliments that's
every photo of him you know the for all
the photos of him with women I people
tried to make it out the day we're
really lascivious I don't think he's
less severe sore lustful or something
like that I think he's just a flattering
oily politician who's always trying to
form an intimate connection with people
and as a result of that if you pay
attention for two seconds you realize
you can't believe a word that the guy
says nevertheless Biden is now the clear
front-runner and he's already screwing
this up we will get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over a
rock Auto I don't know a whole lot about
cars okay when my car has broken down I
don't I don't have a ton of wherewithal
to go and fix my car I go to the brick
and mortar shop right you know what they
they never have the car part in what
they do is they just go online they
probably go to rockauto.com and then
they order the part and then they charge
me a lot more money chain stores have
different price tiers for their
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers and it's it's just a
constant mess Rock Auto calm always
offers the lowest price as possible
rather than changing the prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts The Rock Auto comm catalog is
so good so easy to navigate even I can
navigate it they are a family-owned
company they've been in this business
for a long long time they were really
great I could not recommend them more
highly go to rockauto.com right now and
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right Knowles in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you alright so Joe Biden is
the nominee not the nominee yet he is
the front-runner we'll see maybe after
Super Tuesday he'll become the nominee
but he is the front
he's he's on a straight path to the
nomination and here he is in all his
glory at a rally yesterday Democrats
behold your leader we hold these truths
to be self-evident all men women created
by goal you know this you know the thing
all men and women you and and you know
you know the thing Periclean
Lincolnesque Wow what soaring rhetoric
he's like he's like Reagan and Lincoln
and Pericles combined that's the best
they've got it can't even it's like one
of those famous lines in American
history we hold these truths to be
self-evident and you know you know the
thing if Democrats had nominated this
guy I never want to hear another word
not a peep about how President Trump
talks it's not just once or twice this
is what Joe does all the time but not
another greatest hit on Sunday when he
was wrapping up an interview with Chris
Wallace on Fox News one of the most
famous journalists in the country and he
couldn't remember Chris's name we'll see
you sleepy mr. vice president thank you
thanks for your time please come back in
less than 13 years sir all right thank
you very much all right it's Chris but
anyway
SiC travels on the campaign trail thank
you sir Oh we'll see you sleepy okay I
think we've seen who's sleepy the
problem here is not even that Joe Biden
messed up Chris Wallace's name I mean he
you should know who you're talking to in
an interview or you should have the good
sense just not to say the person's name
but the real trouble that's what he said
at the end he goes oh yeah no Chris man
yeah it's just dim back to back and it's
so early I don't know how you guys do it
Joe Biden is saying that he does not
have the energy and stamina of a TV
newsman but he wants to become the
President of the United States the
leader of the free world that is not a
great pitch for your own candidacy look
if you just say ah sorry I forgot your
name Chris look all you guys look the
same to me I gotta go I gotta go hit the
campaign trail you make a little joke
about it or something that's fine but to
say gosh so early in the morning how do
you guys do it I don't know man you're
supposed to do it if you become the
president so maybe we should rethink
this whole thing my favorite part now is
that the Democrats have three real
options my Elizabeth Warren is not gonna
get out of the race we can get into why
that is in just a second and actually by
the way if you have any questions we're
doing live questions from The Daily wire
subscribers on the website and on the
app so send those questions and we'll
try to get to a few of them during the
show my favorite part about all of this
is that the Democrats now have three
real options the options are the corrupt
dotard this sort of old man who can't
remember the Declaration of Independence
he can't remember what the interviewers
name is that's one the doddering
communists that's two and then the
billionaire philanthropist finance media
mogul who served three mostly successful
terms as mayor of New York City one of
the world's most important cities and
the first two are winning they actually
I'm not saying Mike Bloomberg is a good
candidate in many ways he's like the
worst candidate possible but just
compared to Bernie and Biden Mike
Bloomberg has actually accomplished
quite a lot in his life he's actually in
even though he gets his worldview pretty
wrong and they're gonna give it to the
guy Joe Biden ran for president in 1988
had to pull out because he told very
specific lies about his academic record
and other things ran for president again
20 years later in 2008 didn't do any
better I don't think he won a single
delegate either time now he's running
again twelve years after that total flop
a guy who accomplished very little in
the US Senate and you know Bernie
Sanders who got kicked off a commune for
being too lazy Bernie Sanders who never
had a job until he was 40 years old
Bernie Sanders who's never affected
really any serious legislation and then
you got Mike Bloomberg who's actually
made something of himself actually was a
he was an okay mayor of New York he was
fine you know he's relatively successful
got three terms big career and they're
the Democrats just like absolutely not
no way do we want that successful guy
not a chance
dumb Donald Trump is loving this the
president is having such a great time he
loves the chaos here was president
Trump's reaction to Peabody judges
endorsement of Joe Biden well he just
booted gates just went out and said
something and probably they'll say hey
look if I win I'll put you in the
administration that's called quid pro
quo right quid pro quo and they probably
said hey listen if I win I'll give you
an endorsement but will you take me in
the administration now I'm sure like I'm
sure nothing like that has ever happened
right but that's the way it seems to go
but no it's rigged against Bernie
there's no question about it
what great what a great response he
makes a good point
right the point is what we're seeing
right now is called a quid pro quo hey
you remember when you guys were trying
to impeach me and throw me out of office
for a quid pro quo that I didn't even do
there doing a quid pro quo right now how
come how come you only talk about my
quid pro quo that I didn't even do you
don't talk about their quid pro quo
Trump's strategy importantly is to
highlight his opponents doing the same
and worse as he does right it's this
never explain never apologize always
attack so he's taking every opportunity
just to go
after them to needle them to hit them I
mean how do you attack a guy for
endorsing a political candidate Trump
figured out how to and it was a good
attack then at the very end he gets in
there a complete non sequitur goes down
he goes oh by the way they're gonna
steal it from Bernie alright see you
guys because the Democrats are stealing
it from Bernie has become a sort of
right-wing meme the reason it's become a
meme the reason it's become popular the
reason right wingers are talking about
it is a because it's true the Democrats
are doing their level best to steal this
nomination from Bernie just like they
did it in 2016 but be the reason they're
doing it is because it creates so much
more chaos in the party and the
Conservatives could benefit from this
which we'll get to in just a moment
first I gotta thank our friends over at
NetSuite what do companies like wring
hint to Kovas what do they all have in
common aside from some of them being
sponsors of this show they all use
NetSuite to accelerate their growth
successful companies know that in order
to grow faster you must have the right
tools whether you're doing a million 10
million or hundreds of millions in
revenue NetSuite by Oracle gives you the
tools you need to accelerate your growth
with NetSuite you get a full picture of
your business finance inventory HR
customers and more very often people
can't see all those numbers it stops you
from growing and that's we puts it all
right in front of you gives you the
visibility and control that you need to
make the right decisions and grow with
confidence schedule your free product or
right now and receive your free guides
seven key strategies to grow your
profits at NetSuite comm slash Knowles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles what
is it NetSuite comm /ko wles okay so
right now with Joe in the lead president
Trump is turning his attention back to
Joe Biden so the attack is shifting and
a lot of people aren't catching this the
attack is shifting just from sleepy Joe
that was the original attack on Joe
Biden that Joe doesn't have any stamina
he doesn't have any energy it it's now
shifting to sleepy Joe is surrounding
himself
with radicals I honestly don't think he
knows what office he's running for and
it doesn't matter you know maybe he gets
in because he's a little more moderate
so maybe he gets in but he's not gonna
be running it other people are going to
they're gonna put him into a home and
other people are gonna be running the
country and they're gonna be super left
radical crazies they're gonna be super
left radical crazy Jo's gonna be in a
home he'll be watching television and
everything will be just because are they
gonna put Joe in a home I love this is a
great way to get the joke across right
is the really funny outrageous thing
he's saying is they're gonna put Joe in
a home but he just throws that line away
right so he moves you past that so well
you're still laughing at oh my gosh do
you just say he's gonna put his opponent
in a home then he moves on to but he's
gonna have all these radical crazy young
people around him and the radical crazy
young people are the ones that you've
got to be afraid of this is the
evolution of the attack because I think
President Trump thinks that Bernie is
more beatable in a general election than
Joe Biden this is why he's propping up
Bernie and he's going after Biden and
Bloomberg he just I think Trump doesn't
believe the Americans are gonna elect a
radical socialist and probably the trim
team's got a good Apple file on Bernie
so he keeps saying this right they're
stealing it from Bernie Bernie's getting
robbed he's always kind of defending
Bernie but now he's starting to use the
attacks that he would use in a general
election against Bernie against Biden
which is about the radicalism right he's
he's saying yeah even Joe Biden you
think he's kind of more moderate maybe
but he's a senile old man they're gonna
throw him in a home he's gonna go watch
TV then they're gonna have all these
radicals running the country because
this is a win-win strategy right the
strategy of going after Bernie and
defending or going after Biden and
defending Bernie is not going to turn
off the Bernie bros some of whom
president Trump probably wants to win
over or at least demoralize enough that
they don't come out and vote in the
general election right but at the same
time it gets ready that same attack that
he thinks is going to be effective in a
general election so you know Trump is
tweeting out here just yesterday tweets
that they're staging a coup against
Bernie
few days
Democrats are working hard to destroy
the name and reputation of crazy Bernie
Sanders and take the nomination away
from him I love that they're trying to
destroy the reputation of a man I'm
calling crazy next one the Dems are
working hard to take the prize
nomination away from Bernie backroom
politics which Bernie is not very good
at his people will not let it happen
again this is real political savvy even
the way he talks about the home at the
rally he's talking like a stand-up
comedian he's talking like a political
commentator not as a guy in the race a
guy was in the race would never admit
that there's a chance that his opponent
would win he would never say let's say
he wins and you're gonna be okay with
that right he would say no way we're
gonna we're gonna win it and now my
opponent doesn't stand a chance and
we're gonna go beat him but he stands
back yeah okay let's sit let's say he
wins let's say Biden wins cuz he's a
little more moderate or whatever you're
not gonna like what happens okay because
you're gonna get all these radicals
running it and Biden I'll be in a home
and I'll be watching TV and that'll be
fine he's he's got a little bit of that
distance there and he's just like you
see this crazy political scene you see
what's gonna happen
you guys better you're probably gonna
want me I'm not I'm not begging for it
I'm just saying you're gonna want you're
gonna come begging for me if those
radicals are running the show there's a
big political savvy that's going on here
which is that there are two political
divides in this country okay the two
political divides are left right we
already know that that's when we talk
about all the time the other political
divide is establishment populist okay
and they don't they don't exactly match
up so Trump wants to win suburban voters
by presenting himself as more
establishment than Bernie that's the
that's the pitch of crazy Bernie crazy
radicalism but he wants to mollify he
wants to pacify he wants to kind of make
nice with the Bernie voters by
presenting himself as more populist than
Biden so all that tweet about their
stealing it from Bernie those corrupt
people are rigging it from Bernie that's
all to say hey Bernie Bros you and I
have common cause because we're both
outside the
stablishment but then when he goes out
and he makes the arguments about how
crazy bernie is I was a radical
socialist how Biden's campaign people
are radicals he's making the argument to
the suburban voters to maybe the Biden
voters he says look I'm more
establishment than Bernie Sanders you're
gonna be a lot more comfortable with me
he's making those two at the same time
very very smart strategy I think he's
doing a good job and for people who say
that I'm just saying he's doing for DHS
or something I don't know how conscious
this is it might just be an eight but if
it's an eight then it backs up something
we've been saying for the long time
which is that the guy's got very good
political instincts let's take one
question from the audience before we get
into Super Tuesday before we get into
Chris Matthews his question from a
Michael have moderates Biden and
Bloomberg explicitly stated to your
satisfaction that communism is immoral
or is their only argument against Bernie
that it is a good but impractical idea
no they have not stated to my
satisfaction that communism is immoral
they haven't made that argument at all
unfortunately a lot of right-wingers
have not stated that to my satisfaction
either because everybody's just making
some lame bean-counting economic
argument I mean you you remember when
Barack Obama was president they went
down to Cuba and got absolutely nothing
out of it just gave Cuba everything
didn't take anything in return didn't
get any concessions from the regime and
Barack Obama another guy who talked like
a moderate but actually was a secret
radical he came out and said look these
distinctions between capitalism and
communism they don't really mean that
much for our generation they do they do
mean a lot they are totally different
views of the relationship of the
individual to the state of the local
community to the state of tradition and
history to politics so he said that and
and then Barack Obama had the money line
he said we just care about what works
that's what Mike Bloomberg singing so
socialism doesn't work that's what Joe
Biden is implying I don't even he's not
even saying it that explicitly socialism
doesn't work we're going to do what
works
if by Bloomberg obviously that's all he
cares about is the efficiency of markets
if all you care about is just getting
GDP up a little bit higher or just kind
of making the market a little bit more
efficient then you're you're just as bad
as the hard left is the radical left
some ways you're worse because you're
not viewing people as people and the
human being is much more than just a
commodity is much more than just an
economic product is much more than just
a sort of cog and a machine that can be
greased or oiled or shaped a little bit
better under different regimes the
trouble with communism is that it's it's
evil it's wicked it's a pest it has no
respect for human dignity its atheistic
its materialistic it discounts
everything that matters to us in life
and also it destroys the economy that's
the argument nobody's making it right
now other than I think President Trump
is actually pretty good at making this
argument he makes an argument much more
to the human person than any of the
Democratic candidates okay let's get to
Super Tuesday predictions then we got to
get to Chris Matthews not Chris Wallace
I don't want to pull a Biden but first I
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube you've got to go over and buy
another Kingdom the nightmare feast this
is the book of the podcast that I did
with our very own Andrew Clavin and it
you know rose up he came on with a
number one or it's podcasts in the world
we got three seasons out of it and drew
is now releasing that as a book it's
fabulous it's about an out-of-work a
Dalek Hollywood screenwriter who walks
through a door ends up in another world
which has got ochres and beasts and
swords and all that kind of stuff it's
actually not quite as crazy as Hollywood
but still they're two different
different worlds and it's really
profound I highly highly recommend it I
think it's one of the great works of
fiction that's been made in the last few
years
hit on over and go buy that we got
backstage Super Tuesday is coming up
today and we want to hear from you so
tell us who you think will win the
Democratic nomination by texting either
Biden Bernie Bloomberg or Warren 283 400
and tonight during our backstage we will
analyze the result
live so texts Biden Bernie Bloomberg or
Warren 283 400 and we will analyze those
results on daily wire backstage tonight
that's going to be what's going on
Bernie Sanders is got the most delegates
going into Super Tuesday
so go ahead on over to daily wire use
promo code never socialist to get 25%
off all daily wire membership plans you
know it comes with all the good stuff so
head on over use a coupon code never
socialist 25% off daily wire calm slash
subscribe we'll be right back
we have too much to get to before Super
Tuesday I told you we're gonna do our
best to get through it and we are are on
track so Super Tuesday this is maybe the
biggest thing to look for going into it
right now the Buddha judge Klobuchar
endorsements could have completely
changed the map on Super Tuesday so
Super Tuesday all these different states
are gonna go out and vote before the
club you char and Buddha judge
endorsement if you just look at the
average of the Real Clear Politics polls
here is who was supposed to win the
various states Alabama Biden Arkansas
Bloomberg California Burnie Colorado
Burnie
Maine Burnie Massachusetts Burnie
Minnesota globe you CH are followed by
Bernie North Carolina Biden Oklahoma
Biden in Bloomberg have a tie Tennessee
to Tennessee Tennessee might be Biden
actually don't have that written that
might that'll be a surprise for later
tonight
Texas Bernie Utah Bernie Vermont Bernie
Virginia Bernie massive stuff so Biden
you get what maybe two likely wins one
likely tie Bernie eight likely wins one
likely tie and Bloomberg one likely win
now what happens when you add Pete and
club you chars endorsements so obviously
it's not gonna work out exactly like
this but if Pete and Klobuchar get
exactly the number of votes that the
polls were predicting or if all of those
votes do just transfer over right away
to Joe Biden all of a sudden you've got
Alabama Biden Arkansas Biden California
a slightly Bernie but basically tied
with Biden Colorado Biden Maine Biden
Massachusetts Biden Minnesota Biden
North Carolina Biden Oklahoma Biden
Tennessee Biden Texas Biden Utah tie
between Bernie and Biden Vermont Bernie
obviously in Virginia Biden it becomes a
Biden blowout if the club you char and
Pete boats actually go over to to Joe
Biden and California is basically a tie
even California with a slight Bernie
edge now the big wild card here is going
to be Mike Bloomberg Mike Bloomberg is
not giving up after
buta judge and Klobuchar got out
bloomberg was asked whether he would get
out - I think you know his answer early
on today and Amy just blew a while ago
and I wish them all the best I thought
both of them behaved themselves a phrase
it but they represented their country
and their states very well and I'm sorry
for them but I'm in it to win it I love
this guy I love that Mike Bloomberg has
such condescension that he would say yes
well I felt that mood to judge and
Klobuchar they behaved themselves they
didn't cause me too much of a problem if
they had of course I would have wiped
them off the face of the earth but no no
they were good little kiddies all right
kiddies go away now you know Buda jegeon
Club you sure they have to play nice
they have to get out early they have to
make the smart endorsement right they're
young people they relatively young they
have their political careers ahead of
them they don't have sixty billion
dollars like Mike Bloomberg Bloomberg
doesn't have to worry about any of that
you know Elizabeth Warren didn't get out
she didn't get out when Klobuchar and
Buddha judge did why not because
Elizabeth Warren is not quite as young
as Klobuchar and booted yet she's got a
little less to lose in her political
career this might be the last chance
that she could run for president so
she's just gonna stick in it at
Bloomberg certainly this is his last
chance so listen to this response listen
to a response that Mike Bloomberg gave
to a voter at a town hall on Fox who
said hey I'm a gun owner I'm a regular
American Second Amendment supporter how
come I'm not allowed to have a gun and
protection but you Mike Bloomberg are
allowed to walk around with armed
security how do you justify pushing for
more gun control when you have an armed
security detail that is likely equipped
with the same firearms and magazines
that you seek to ban the common citizen
from owning does your life matter more
than mine or my families or these
people's fire
but I probably get 40 or 50 threats
every week okay and some of them are
real that just happens when you're the
mayor in New York City or you're very
wealthy and if you're campaigning for
president United States you get lots of
threats so I have a security detail I
pay for it all myself and you know
they're all retired police officers who
are very well trained in firearms I love
this guy I love that he gives at every
opportunity the worst political answer
you could possibly give you goes that
you are you saying mr. Bloomberg that
your life matter more is than mine
Bloomberg more or less says yes I am and
I'm saying that because I'm rich and
famous it's just good look listen you
peasant
I get threats against me because I am a
famous politician and by the way very
very wealthy and and look look I pay for
my security myself because did I mention
that I'm wealthy I'm very wealthy much
much richer than you and that's why I
need to have more rights than you have
peasant perfect what a great weight
great way to to connect with the voters
I get a real kick out of Mike
Bloomberg's elitism probably not going
to play well in Peoria in some ways he
would be the best choice that the
Democrats have because he wouldn't just
completely destroy the country in some
ways he's the worst choice though
because it's pretty clear that Mike
Bloomberg doesn't really like people all
that much he doesn't seem to have a
great respect for people he he just
wants to run their lives he just wants
to tell them what to do but he doesn't
he doesn't really seem to connect with
them review them as human just as cogs
in a machine I mean he said the
president is a managerial job that tells
you everything you need to know about
the way he views the world but he's
probably not going to do that well
anyway so going into tonight it's
biden's to lose we're gonna see if South
Carolina was a fluke or whether whether
it was the beginning of the end of the
Democrat nomination now Klobuchar and
Buddha ginger not the only left-wingers
to drop out in recent days they're the
only presidential candidates to
that in recent days but there's another
major left winger who dropped out
yesterday that would be Chris Matthews
on MSNBC Chris Matthews came on last
night shocking to everybody he's had
this show hardball for 20 years now on
MSNBC he goes out and he says hey my
first story I'm retiring I'm out here's
chris matthews is reasoning let me start
with my headline tonight i'm retiring
this is the last hardball in MSNBC and
obviously this isn't for lack of
interest in politics as you can tell
I've loved every minute of my 20 years
as host of hardball every morning I read
the papers and I'm gung ho to get to
work not many people have had this
privilege I love working with my
producers and the discussions we have
over how to report the news and I love
having this connects with you the good
people who watch so right off the bat
right off the bat you realize that Chris
Matthews did not choose to retire Chris
Matthews was pushed out by NBC MSNBC I
mean he says it explicitly says
obviously I'm not losing interest in
politics obviously I'm not losing
interest in you I love this job I love
working with people but I've got to go
and then he explains why he's got to go
conversation with MSNBC I decided
tonight will be my last hardball so let
me tell you why the younger generation
is out there ready to take the reins we
see them in politics in the media and
fighting for their causes they are
proving the workplace we're talking here
about better standards than we grew up
with fair standards a lot of it has to
do with how we talk to each other
compliments on a woman's appearance that
some men including me might have once
incorrectly thought were okay we're
never okay not then is certainly not
today and for making such comments in
the past I'm sorry
there it is he got me too Chris Matthews
one of the real Titans of left-wing
commentary and actually a left winger
who I always got a kick out of I mean he
was wrong about so many things he got
that he said he got a thrill up his leg
when he saw Barack Obama I mean he there
are many many many most things he got
wrong but I was got a kick out of him he
always seemed like sort of a straight
shooter in that he was saying what he
believed and he was kind of funny about
it he was kind of ornery so I I'm sorry
to see him go he got me too and I'm
really sorry to see see him go the
that he did because I this I said oh
maybe Chris Matthews is some big
womanizer maybe he's been sleeping with
all the women at the show maybe he's
pulled a Matt Lauer maybe stepping out
on his wife all the time or something no
that's not it you you heard him talk
about it there he said people make
comments and sometimes those comments
are wrong and I shouldn't have made
those comments ISM kind of comments did
he may he's a commentator what kind of
comments did he make so I looked up the
article that's in GQ magazine i Laura
Bassett this is the article that
ostensibly got Chris Matthews fired and
she gives all the reasons all the
horrible things he did here they are
it's called like Warren I had my own
sexist run-in with Chris Matthews so
she's objecting to something Chris
Matthews did with Elizabeth Warren to
the article begins I believe the woman
which means he's not telling the truth
said Warren who recently had to defend
her own credible story of pregnancy
discrimination applause right there that
first line is a lie she doesn't have a
credible story of pregnancy
discrimination Elizabeth Warren is now
saying that she was fired from her first
teaching job because she got pregnant
but we have her on video you from years
ago talking about how she didn't get
that teaching job she didn't keep the
teaching job because she lacked a
credential and lacked interest and
wanted to stay home with her kid her own
words I'm not making that up that's what
she said then she's lying about it now
and then this writer Laura Bassett
writing in GQ is lying about Warren's
lies not a good way to start off the
article if you're gonna try to torpedo a
guy's career the article goes on and why
would he lie Matthews said just to
protect himself yeah and why would she
lie
Warren responded pointedly there was no
reason I'm skipping around a little bit
but you get the point
there was no reason for him to harp on
its veracity except perhaps that he
himself has made so many sexist comments
over the years that he has a vested
interest in Bloomberg being let off the
hook and going after Warren
so she's accusing him of sexism here it
is not sexist to observe that Elizabeth
Warren is a liar
Warren is one of the most famous
infamous and egregious liars in the
entire country
she lied for decades about her ancestry
and said that she the whitest woman in
the world was a Native American she did
that at elite universities she did that
possibly taking jobs away from actual
Native Americans
she then lied about the pregnancy
discrimination she then lied very
recently about where her children went
to school lies about everything
there's nothing sexist about calling a
liar a liar but you know this woman in
using the kind of meat to era as a
political cudgel is using sexism the way
that the left has used racism for so
many years which is not to point out an
actual example of bigotry but just to
silence your political opponent matthews
has a pattern of making comments about
women's appearances in demeaning ways
the number of on-air incidents is long
exhausting and creepy including
commenting to erin burnett for example
you're a knockout
it's alright getting bad news from you
while telling her to move closer to the
camera regardless of whether you think
that a MSNBC host should compliment
people's appearances it is simply a fact
that what he said is not demeaning she's
saying he's made demeaning comments well
what was the comment the comment was
you're a knockout
that's not demeaning it's a compliment
now you could say it's not it's wrong to
compliment people in the workplace never
give anyone a compliment okay that's
fine fair enough if we're living in this
politically correct culture fine we can
all go along with that but you can't lie
about it and say that it's demeaning it
simply was not even this were the the
word creepy he had two word creepy in
here creepy is just a way to to you know
slander somebody without having to give
any kind of example and Chris Matt look
I have a lot of criticisms of charisma
Chris Matthews but I only he's creepy
she goes on hey she talks about an
interview with Hillary Clinton he
suggested that Clinton had only had so
much political success because her
husband had messed around yup no one
would know Hillary Clinton's name
if she wasn't Miss
as Clinton she was the first lady of
Arkansas then the first lady of the
United States and then she immediately
after leaving the White House became the
senator from New York a state she had
never lived in do you think she became
the senator of New York because Hillary
is just so famously good at connecting
with voters hmm don't think so think it
probably had something to do with her
last name she goes on in 2017 I wrote a
personal essay about a much older
married cable news host to
inappropriately flirted with me in the
makeup room a few times before we went
live on his show making me noticeably
uncomfortable on-air I was afraid to
name him at the time afraid to name him
for all the flirting the traumatic
flirting for fear of retaliation from
the network I'm not anymore
it was Chris Matthews in 2016 right
before I had to go on his show and talk
about sexual assault allegations against
Donald Trump totally bogus allegations
by the way where how many years are we
into the Trump presidency they got
nothing on him goes on Matthews looked
over at me in the makeup chair next to
him and he said why haven't I fallen in
love with you yet oh my gosh Oh miss
Bassett I'm so sorry this happened to
you I hope that you get millions of
dollars from MSNBC to pay for the years
of therapy that you will need to recover
from Chris Matthews saying why haven't I
fallen in love with you yet in a public
setting without inviting you to dinner
without inviting you to his hotel room
without inviting you to his office like
Matt Lauer does just a slightly
flirtatious comment
good grief then she gets to the bottom
and she says that Chris Matthews needs
to be fired having a news anchor who
calls women she-devil by the way he only
did that to Hillary Clinton and it
happens to be correct and treats their
assessments with infantilizing suspicion
he treated Elizabeth Warren with
infantilizing suspicion because she
infantilized herself by lying all the
time while conducting post-debate
interviews builds in a major
disadvantage for female candidates it's
downright irresponsible she brings up
math uses employment this is absurd this
woman should be ashamed of herself me
too has obviously jumped the shark
nitu is addressing an actual problem the
actual problem is all of these mostly
left-wing men in power in media and
politics acting like complete
degenerates and abusing women that's a
real problem
did I mention they're mostly Democratic
mostly left-wing men who have been doing
it like Harvey Weinstein and Matt Lauer
and all of the other ones yeah I just
wanted to make sure I got that in there
that started out to address a real
problem and now it has become a cynical
tool to be wielded with impunity only
when it is politically convenient that's
it that's all it is it's sad it's
pathetic because by the way Chris
Matthews is not being fired for this me
two thing because he made a flirtatious
comment in the makeup room or something
the reason he's being fired is because
he's now not left-wing enough for the
Democratic Party he's not left-wing
enough for his network and he's a very
left-wing guy but the other day he came
out and came out against Bernie Sanders
and it'd be bad if Bernie Sanders got
the nomination the other day came he's
made a few on-air gaffes right but he's
made on-air gaffes throughout his whole
career yeah there was this incident is
kind of embarrassing where he confused
two black politicians and thought one
was the other one and it was very
awkward but he's been doing this kind of
stuff for years he's been talking the
way he talks for years the thing that
changed is the Democratic Party which is
now but in terms of just the delegate
count is ready to nominate an open
avowed socialist an actual communist who
honeymooned in the Soviet Union and
Chris Matthews is from an older school
the fight that we're seeing in the
Democratic Party nomination right now
the Biden Bernie fight is the fight that
we're seeing on MSNBC it's the fight
that we're seeing in left-wing
commentary it's the fight that we're
seeing in the media and that fight is
only gonna heat up through November last
question before we get to it before we
get to Super Tuesday later tonight this
is from Jay f who would be more
beneficial to Biden as a VP club you
char or Budaj Club you char would having
a woman probably would be more
beneficial I think women out ranked gay
men
on the intersectional victimhood scale
no I don't I don't think Buddha jej
would be a great VP candidate the only
advantage he would have is he could
debate Mike Pence and the left could
pretend that Mike Pence is some big
homophobe or something like that but I
suspect it's actually gonna be someone
totally different
I don't think klog EHR or Buddha judge
these kind of fairly weak presidential
candidates I don't think that they're
they're gonna be the best choice I think
you could see someone from somewhere
else in politics maybe an another name
we've heard who hasn't been around in a
little while you know that that's
probably more likely there's 300 million
people to choose from so they don't need
to just choose from the the handful who
have made it this far in the democratic
race all right
stick around later we will get to Super
Tuesday we have so much more to get to
but we'll have to save that for tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle well
tune in to the Ben Shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there